no speaking about with dynamics of fun
spaces my name is Emily and
unfortunately Joe and Rob are
conferences we're gonna thank them in
advance so this summer we worked with
work on project and dynamics of that
spaces so I'm just going to give a
little spoiler and how to cut sharp in
that space because it's going to be
useful later and I'll leave the
construction
so let's faces our quotients of
asclepius new key actions so so more
precisely that and find the action by
this matrix
so we're defining the action of this on
honest week and this makes sense because
that's the reason
and so the quotient of this action on s3
is going to be called in that space
our PQ and I'm just gonna leave this
here because it'll be useful for a
carrot to use later so now that we have
this so let's talk about some motivation
for this talk of its project so let's
bases are something that will define
they're called contact manifolds and
contact magnifier or objects in contact
geometry and what care about cosmic
geometry collect geometry sort of the
dimensional analog of symplectic
geometry and symplectic geometry has
been around for hundreds of years it's
served the natural environment to study
classical mechanics and string theory so
and the hamiltonian vector field in in
physics is sort of the analog of a
replica field which will define later
and so why we care about men's faces
these lab spaces are our simplest
examples of closed oriental buddha three
manifolds and they they're the first
type of three manifolds that have not
that are not entirely described by their
fundamental group enthalpy there's
actually l5 1 and l5 - or not
but they do have isomorphic mental
groups so when spaces are just really
nice so now that we have some motivation
let's talk about some background we'll
be using throughout the talk an N
dimensional manifold is a topological
space that little opening like RM I'm
going to go through this really fast
this everyone here knows this the
tangent space is just a an n-dimensional
vector space at each point spanned by
the tangent vectors at that point and a
one form is a linear function on the tan
space so now that we have some basic
background I know what the French rule
manifold is they talk about what a
contact my goodness and a contact
manifold it is a differentiable manifold
with contact structure and a contact
show sure is a maximally non interval
hyperplane distribution and assuming you
guys don't know what these words mean
right off the bat I'll explain them
now so what contact distribution what
you have which you should have in mind
is hyperplanes of each tangent space
such that these hyper planes do not make
the tangent bundle of a smaller manifold
so it's much better if I have a picture
so what are hyper planes of tender
spaces there are 3 their plates each
point we have a plane here and what I
mean that these can't make the depending
on their so I'm smaller pitiful we try
to glue these things together we
obviously need to rip it down the middle
so now that we have some idea of what a
contact structure is let's try thinking
about how we can find them so if alpha
is a one form on your manifold such that
alpha which the alpha to the N minus 1
is a volume form then the kernel of this
is going to be a contact structure and
we call one forms that satisfy this
condition a contact form and in our case
of r3 here we have alpha is DZ plus X dy
and we can easily compute it off the
wedge D alpha is DX which dy which the
Hz which is the volume form on our three
so the parallel this is the concept
structure that we see in this book so
let's do another example we know that a
dimensional spheres can be embedded in
r2 n which can be identified with CN
through these coordinates so if we
define this all over one form alpha zero
and restricted on the dimensional sphere
then it's a compound form and you guys
can check for yourself
alpha zero watch the alpha 0 to the N
minus 1 who is a volume from Armin for
the sphere so it doesn't manage anywhere
and the colonel of this is the is what
we like to call the standard contact
structure on the sphere and sort of a
trivial example but we'll be using it
throughout the rest of the slides are
estimated on our four it's a two and you
can define as a level set of this
function and so the standard contact
form is going to be given by this
circuit W simply so now that we know
what contact benefits are let's try to
define one they are similar so to
contact manifolds are said to be contact
amorphic if there's a diffuse on from
one to the other such that the push
board of one contact structure is the
same thing as the context are shown on
the second one and we can define this
duct we can find contact a morphisms
with contact form so if the first
contact structure is the kernel of some
form alpha one and the second one is the
kernel of some form alpha 2 then we say
they are contact amorphic if the pull
back the second form is g times the
first one and why does this make sense
it makes sense because the kernel of g
times alpha one is same it is the same
thing as the kernel about the one thing
G is strictly positive and when when we
have and this leads us to the conclusion
that the contact structure of the
parallel f1 and the
that structure of Geo who are the same
so let's look at an example r3 with the
kernel of the one form we showed earlier
and r3 with the kernel of this form our
contact amorphic and in fact these are
something we like to call strictly
contact of norfolk which means that not
only are the contact structure is the
same but these two contact forms are
also the same so when we have morphisms
like contact the morphisms obviously one
thing we study are invariants on their
contact with your physicals however
there's something that's not a ban which
is very important to our project this
and these are so given a contact form
alpha and the contact structure the
kernel of this alpha then the red vector
field is the unique vector field
determined by these two equations and
the first equation is a normalization
requirement and the second one is that
transversality remark which says that
the red vector field is transverse to
the contact structure so when we have
vector fields the natural thing to do is
flow along these vector fields so we
call the red flow
just the usual integral along the vector
field we know so now that we have this
it's you might have realized that it's
very important which form we have we
want to mean by that is the red flow is
not the state of some form of
is not the same as the rate flow of Jia
even though G alpha and alpha have the
same contact structure obviously if
alpha R equals 1 G alpha R is not going
to be equal to 1 so we have we can have
to contact metals which have the same
context rapture for wildly different
great dynamics because a flow is
dependent on archers so let's get an
example so this is the alpha zero that I
defined earlier and rather dr. field is
given like this and in case you don't
believe me this you can see that if when
alpha zero eats this form we're gonna
have the sum of the norm Z 0 is 1 which
1 s 3 is 1 so health of heart is better
people to 1 so we can solve the
differential equation that gives us flow
and here it is so here's the rib flow
and these are orbits because at every
point can come back to the same point
and these might look little less
familiar to some of you because the rate
orbits unless three are the hot factors
which are our topological object that
it's studied but we will not mention it
in the rest of the talk
or taxable so now
so now that you know general things
about the space working so we're take
the finite sub group su 2 of C that's
given by the following matrix as I'm
sure you can see this guy someone McTeer
C n plus one see the London space we're
considering is X 3 bumpass gamma this is
called the lens space Allen this is a
this is a manifold because our action is
free everywhere except at the origin
where it's a fixed point and it's a
contact manifold because the contact
form and compact structure both descent
to the portions but this is actually a
little bit annoying to work with this
portion to sort of think about so we're
gonna have to realize this is another
way as what's called a link of a hyper
super singularity so you do some algebra
you can identify the entire c2 mod
gabelle with a hypersurface in c3 you do
this by taking some like basis of
invariance
in situ mah gamma and during a change of
coordinates and us and then this also
has a singularity at the origin because
the derivative does not rank and this
corresponds to the previous fixed point
of the opportunity the option to resolve
the singularity of what we do is be
taken deep what's called a link by
intersecting with the five sphere a very
primitive example of that is shown in
this somewhat crude picture but you have
you have a singular point here answer
all of your like hyper sir was there and
you resolve that by sort of intersecting
with this circle and this also gives a
contact structure by taking the subset
of the tangent bundle that's invariant
under under what's basically
multiplication by an ID
and since and so now you have these two
conic manifolds and not to our
supervisors it is it their conduct or
morphic so we can look at this one when
we want to study the previous and to be
are interested in the sort of dynamics
of the red vector field
and study that proper thing we need to
make a non-degenerate formed that's
defined an object format to define it
not generate or miss and that's just an
orbit that's isolated and namjoon reform
is a form all of whose main formats are
not integers so this is a generic
property given a contact form you can
always return it to make it non
degenerate most common forms are not
regenerate but this is not a
constructive process if you want one you
have to make one and what we care that's
because a lot of the important
invariants that I'm going to talk about
them later
only makes sense with nonagenarian
orbits unfortunate this data product
form on the sphere is generous because
as you saw earlier there's a periodic
orbit and each of those since in both
cases L sort of gets its contact
structure from s3 or s5 in some sense
it's also they're also different the
standard forms you get so what did we do
we determines in on the general form
that looks like this we basically
generalize a method of with Salafi moon
in this for a different class of
manifolds and
by sort of taking an existing form and
then adding in some a small
international number that's sort of like
perturbs it so you only get three
periodic orbits and
so now that we and this is actually
contact amorphic to the standard form
gifts for those five pence also the
format guestrooms three so so all of our
the stuff we do here can sort of
translate so now we know what we haven't
done that will hopefully lead students
getting some important content prepared
well the first thing is something called
a condom use either index for each rate
limits
that's a dynamical index for the orbit
that that's just an integer you need
isolated orbits because if you don't
spend this thing is invariant around
which would be and once we get this we
can hopefully get what's called the
contact homology of I'll this this most
similar to being to this that you may be
seen in the course more symbology but
instead of critical points you talk
about instead of critical points you
have three orbits and so unlike from
like it's up like paths you have
internal pseudo hole in your curves and
if you go from like a red border to a
rave orbit whose index is colonies and
indexes like to lower or something and
so what we want is arc on these indexes
to be all even or all on or something
because then the like algorri map is
trivial and then contacts homology is
not generally what
clients because you kind of coffee you
have two problems you have to get a
content to let it make sense and you
have to prove that it sort of that
distance invariant under under your
contact a morphism even when you go back
to to a to like something I'm pretty
sure this is these this thing is
multiplying four three four three
manifolds but not we're not sure about
beyond and a lot of people are sort of
working on sort of fixing this theory in
technology including our supervisor and
also I think helmet hold for FBI is
thank you listening we would like to
thank the math are you for everything
it's possible we'd like to thank our
supervisors Joe Nelson England
Castellano and we'd also like like to
thank Jimmy ogle and it's our stuffy
picnic attached we're also sort of
helping us out there any questions
you came up with this as well as an
annotation of another
analogous
it's
yes
okay so basically the idea is that you
have some in our case students like the
brain flows are like e to the 2 to the I
something look similar on the sphere and
these you have some coefficients but
like like with this sphere of piece you
can just you can just pick a period and
like you'll always have a period so what
you do is you kind of insert these small
little like rationally independent
epsilon so you don't get a period in
common
we add one to one of them and then we
subtract the epsilon from the other so
these are obviously not rational
any more questions